okay just a heads up the audio on this
sounds a little off it's because we're
using a different camera we're testing
the 4k camera on my computer with it so
[Music]
[Laughter]
was this movies fucking this yeah this
is the one twice okay okay here we go
I was 32 but the thing I liked about
Thor Thor too was that there was way
less natalie portman
anyway computer skarsgård there was
still less of them in Thor 2 than there
wasn't the first one they were alone
it's like now the movies kat dennings
movie chilling comedy away no this is
before we fucking why did we desert its
we took on eighties album cover the
movies and I said 80s metal cover the
movie yeah they're like every action
scene it ain't all
so cool oh my god it's like yeah we got
a we got a Thor movie it's like an
eighties Thor movie
it's just that the soundtrack is all a
DS and got some cool songs on there the
effects are really cool even when their
faith they look amazing
jump Goldblum is a villain oh yeah a
trip to oh and that he gives comedy gold
there's two villains and this one is
funny what is threatening and funny
about scene okay playing - she's having
a ball she's chewing so much scenery I
think that's how she was gonna destroy a
scar yeah I think she was gonna eat it
just eat all of the set design because
for years only good Marvel villain we
had was Loki and even that it's like
it's weird that that's are the best
Marvel because there's a lot of good
Marvel villains out there and then you
know one of the best lines of the movie
though and uh what is it the holsters
like or banners just like so last time
it you know you were trying to kill us
so like some what are you up to now is
it it varies for a moment I'm just
realize all the good Marvel villains in
the movies are green because you got
Loki vulture and yeah Thor sister here I
forgot her name over a but she was
really cool
Thor sister uh yeah evil evil Galadriel
yeah like she cheesy
no it's glad really if she took the
goddamn ring yeah
yeah and she's she's awesome and
hilarious and does all sorts of cool
stuff everybody does cool stuff in this
movie I can't think of like any dead
weight like even the stuff that's like
okay this is just there for comedy or
filler or whatever like it works and
it's fun and it looks amazing and it's
funny even the few dramatic moments are
in here aren't legitimately dramatic and
really worth but yes but it's like the
weight Ghostbusters can be dramatic once
or twice oh yeah it's still the galaxy
I'm not like well there's a happy Holi
Khanna see that you're India see that's
what this movie reminded me of and
that's sacrilegious to say but it
reminded me of like Ghostbusters the way
just there were just so many funny lines
and like a lot of the best bits felt
like they were improvised I had no idea
they were yeah but it just had that vibe
to where it's like you're just gonna see
some ridiculous shit but you're just
gonna have an amazing time and they got
good actors to deliver this dialogue
because i'm kiza
these lines written and I'm like if I
read half of these lines I wouldn't get
a lap but you got Jeff Goldblum you know
though he says anything is hilarious you
guys you gotta keep playing Chapman
really judging it awesome they and
looking cool while doing it authority
actually is great comedic timing and
Loki is great comedian Anthony Hopkins
as Loki is hilarious or the funniest
things in the movies yeah I cuz you said
they were you have to do is just like
you know like just what a great actor
Anthony Hopkins is like well we already
knew that like long history of but just
to be able to sell Loki in his body like
I just that's all I saw anyhow it smoky
if you pokey and Odin's like it I didn't
think oh it's Anthony Hopkins doing a
performance I literally bought that that
was danced and I loved him on the hello
an actor is so good it's like man yeah
you see exactly what you're supposed to
say that who knew um as we were saying
one of the best
Hulk movie
me yeah I just like that that somehow
they tucked the best Hulk movie into
thor ragnarok
it's kinda like I'm Deadpool was in a
way the best x-men movie you know it's
like sometimes pretty good but oh yeah
oh you was yeah you would do the gritty
hits you guys okay no let's take your
glasses you know x3 was really like the
best of the movies along the spider-man
3 you know so there's two because years
from now if we're lucky to have this
video is still there's two things that
they're really big right now what is
that somehow Marvel movies can do no
wrong right now it's kind of creepy it's
just oh wait can you want miss it when
you're looking back at this from a
future well right now with the idea of
anyone skipping a Marvel movie is kind
of insane cuz it's like well why would
you do that
they just of course it's gonna be at the
very least good no no I'm saying like
now like the now state of Marvel it's
like you know there's I would dream of
you know missing Black Panther I
wouldn't dream of missing it anymore
when dream of missing any of the Marvel
movies coming out and I mean it's like
just it seems like meses now I know I'm
trying to think of it like it's there
Marvel movie coming out that I want to
so you wanna know what they're doing now
that this movie really does I wanna say
it probably started with guardians of
the galaxy what they're doing now with
Marvel films like that that has me
really excited before okay it was
characters it was superheroes in those
great now they're doing worlds I really
feel like they're creating world that we
can go to at the putting the characters
in there and giving us new characters
and having fun I feel like cuz it's
gotten so big
I wanted to see Thor wander around the
desert with Natalie Portman yeah oh my
god the secret side shafted like many my
guys literally I swear to god it
practically went like this yeah but
you're dating Natalie Portman no yeah I
was a bad Felicia really I don't like
she was work one of the worst things in
those four the only lines I am naughty
became the only lines like a shame she
dumped you
I'm sorry good stuff but no you want to
talk about not giving a crap and phoning
it in like it is so clear like that was
just hand me my pager
attendings is awful but I can tell she's
trying trying and Suze Orman just didn't
show up
yeah I'm almost convinced that it was a
CGI oh no like the second thing the
second they just like made it clear like
no we're done what there I was like yes
not appearing in this movie yeah it's
like just that was Natalie Portman right
there yeah and they keep it too you know
and even then it's like Thor goes to
this weird place that you wouldn't even
think is like you know these comics
books it's like you know I can see you
know the kind of character Thor and the
strange weird place is kind of like a
garbage city and there's like a you know
an arena or they file the gladiators
button space it's like yeah I can
totally see this this is the Thor movie
we always wanted it yeah it's an
eighties Hubble cover yeah that's what
it's I don't even know I don't even know
what to say
like kind of just I'm trying to think if
there's anything wrong with me yeah
there's not like the pit like I there
were a few moments rooms like it's a
little slow like but this minor shit
like I'm trying to like the process
there there was a moment there's a
moment near the end where I turned you
and I said we have a Valkyrie in a
spaceship firing a Gatling gun with the
Incredible Hulk at a giant fucking wolf
riding over a rainbow bridge this is
what the best movies ever met dick and
the climb you know Lovings Marvel climax
is you know with the exception like
Avengers like you know usually there's
two things going at yeah usually one but
sometimes too you know did something
make here k so this one there's like
four or five things going on every one
of them looks amazing yeah every one of
them is bad you think it couldn't get
bigger and crazier they throw something
else on there and they do it with these
funny characters are counseling throwing
great lines and but you care for him too
and yeah like okay any problems at all I
mean like my stuff is so nitpicky I was
like when that Valkyrie shows up she's
supposed to be a drunk I'm like okay she
can look a little Messier like this
super duper game like from a story
perspective
I thought they they were just like
uh-huh you will have vengeance where you
you saw your your Valkyrie breath and
murdered innocent man I kind of thought
there was gonna be a little more with
her yeah the shoes for a little bit in
the climax I was like man you built her
up so much I thought length one
specially after that there is a gorgeous
flashback only seconds long but I mean I
was just very I love like that was great
loved painting sequence in Wonder Woman
yeah that's like that game and I hate I
don't like dissing one of them because I
enjoyed the hell I didn't but this is
this one was even better close be odd be
effective
we're not very good I mean this one even
plays it even when they're bad they look
amazing I should say Ben even when
they're fake you know but again this is
a movie where you can get away because
they're throwing so much okay like the
giant wolf am I the only one who laughed
because it kind of reminded me of like
the effects of my cum fury where they
just get just a wolf and just like into
the picture that's kind of the vibe of
this film yeah and it really it really
works it like it doesn't necessarily
look real
it actually looks kind of fake but it
looks amazing but I looked awesome yeah
no it's always what I mean would be
bright you know hcg it's like no no it's
either gotta look real or it's got a
little good and this it doesn't look
real it looks good it looks so good
there's no nothing cgi in this movie
look real but it looked artistic yeah it
was just done in style it was really
styling yeah I mean like I said you just
those shots of that flash bag with the
Valkyrie and again I need this it's not
long I don't even think it's a minute
and it's just on every one of those
images I'm just like this Santa graffia
in this film was just blowing my mind
yeah that's been one with the floor
where it does the full oh yeah I know
what the hell they did but that was like
the full that wasn't even the full 360
that was like it yeah just doesn't see
where we're located about three or
walking it's a mere floor so can I see
it before it's above and it goes into
the reflection and turns upside down to
show Jim full of fluid
talking to them and we're just need to
do that I mean nothing in this movie you
need to just know we're gonna be like
did you enjoy that we just spent like
ten thousand dollars on it was amazing
yes his line delivery in this is just so
Goldblum it's of my favors I study that
he became self-aware
he has his finishing line stay for the
end credits yeah but his finishing line
just like the screening we saw they were
hobbling yeah the movie at the very end
and then my favorite though was just the
way he said that was it it was like it
spoiler he's like you know what the hell
is gonna happen in a movie like this
it's like oh they escaped yeah and he
just says something like he's escaped
he's escaped in my ship and all you know
he's escaped in my favorite ship along
with my favorite champions like like
half of his lines out take to the
streets no I mean they I feel like both
him and the makers of this bill know how
to use their Jeff Goldblum because they
have a giant hologram of him talking to
the city just over the city this giant
monster it's Jeff Goldberg babe oh yeah
he doesn't change his toe and I look
people please up find the escaped yes
you'll just randomly you know escape
with my parents
yeah so it's a dressing they my fan ok
so there's so many great shots in the
film my favorite shot though like this
one just kind of blew my mind because it
really put me just in that universe it's
when the Valkyries up in the ship
watching the show yeah sure said she
just just hanging her feet off this open
airship almost like it's Lourdes Stadium
yeah and she's just watching and
drinking from up there I was like I feel
like I'm up there oh yeah
that would be like the best frickin seat
in the house and you would be able to
fight it's like something you felt like
you were just up there and sitting and
the weight kind of shook and she shook
with in stuff and the ankle it's like
yeah there's a lot of shots like that
with the soundtrack yeah I thought that
when I saw that trailer was like oh
that's awesome to be a grandson I got a
little bit tough but it's exactly in the
movie the only thing I mean it's so
nitpicky um there's no surprises in that
really if you seen the trailer I mean
it's like it's the exact movie you think
you're gonna get but like that trailer
looks awesome and this movie is awesome
you know the people are just like Harry
ever maybe they're nothing but jokes you
probably gonna be like anime game is
nothing but jokes but they were funny
joke yeah if you look at the trailer
you're like not for me it's not for you
if you look at you
that was awesome pretty awesome I mean
it really is not in any way false
advertising it's just it's a space 80s
metal sci-fi fantasy action fusion thing
yeah I'm not gonna take it super
seriously like I'm okay with it being
guilty like that was my problem with the
first film is I thought there were too
many times there was two super serious
and then they're fuckin wandering in the
desert and I'm like well what the hell
is this at least the super serious movie
you know was you know at least had some
cool visuals and now I've just got a
Natalie Portman phoning it in and then
the second one like I don't remember the
villains oh can you forget the dark
world Rob I mean that visionary
incredible realm the dark green and they
just happened to stumble across the hole
to get oh so stupid
do you see now
so it had that at least but but no I
don't remember that all I remember
though was that I felt like it went in a
much quicker pace because the characters
I hated in the first one were relegated
more to the sidelines to the point that
I think they were saying they just kind
of out of Natalie Portman's because I
had the other way around with the second
one I was just like because at least in
the first one he's there with the
characters I like him la Chris Chris
Hemsworth so it's one of those things
where it's like I'm with you there I
hated that no and I get that but at
least you still at him in the second one
it's like okay well he's somewhere else
now we're gonna come to only the humans
and I'm just like Oh everybody still
that I felt like faced a bit less screen
time finding oh it was only them it's
like what do you take just a constant
light punch for a long time for just
like nothing that you I didn't love Thor
- but I thought it was that I'm like
that's alright that's fine like it that
maybe Stockholm Syndrome kicked in cuz I
realize I'm like well I'm not gonna get
a real for me yeah I'll just accept this
because there's less of the annoying
shit that bothered me in the first one
but this yeah this is what I wanted we
finally got a condemned for movie ya
know it's uh it's really cool yeah what
would you even say about it's just it's
exactly what you would expect it Heidi
in the best way so we know we've got
black panther then is it infinitely more
black panther it was looking like the
Thundercats movie I never got black
panther is just looking fucking amazing
yeah I mean like when you see the giant
like you know like that castle that's
also like you know like a panther girl
like this giant cat and then there
dressed like a soap just like oh my god
it's like Duggar kids I'm like Thunder
it's it's Thundercats shaft goes down
which looks easy no yeah uh this can't
be I have to look at the wind still has
a bit isn't it me is it that early oh
it's two parts that's right so yeah it
could be but yeah but yeah if Black
Panthers good then to go from these two
movies and should I have to look it up
because I but to go into infinity war
after these two like and cards to the
yam chips eh Louise yeah family rage
Jesus Christ I mean while I sit there
that Justice League trio it comes on and
Superman opens his mouth and I was like
already distresses that would be fair
Wonder Woman and Aquaman and Batman
popped up I'm like okay we're okay maybe
this helps your eye sees flat CG them
against it's like I'm gross of the lines
but it's like you grabs me what else
happen I'm like I remember red I don't
know I don't know I I'm hoping it's good
I want it we've had a perfect that it's
been perfect as it for the comic book
moving so far no like this here now we
have Wonder Woman we had guardians of
the galaxy to I'm sure somebody I'm
trying to think of a common actual kind
of like I'm not trouble like
transformers fight that we don't know
I'm talking about comic book actual
comic book movies like weekend shooting
but but I have a idea seems for the
Marvel DC properties so far this year
mmm yeah no I swear to god it Justice
League fucks up that record then that's
word we're never perfect cuz Black
Panther looks like it's gonna be good
yeah you know but okay here's what's
kind of funny about this cuz again this
is one of the reasons I was saying like
right now
Marvel kind of can't do wrong you know
like they do skipping what seems insane
right now
like it's getting to a point where it's
like no no melody stuff do you remember
a lousy those TV though they're starting
to exit slip up just a year ago do your
and maybe even two years ago do you
remember people can say yeah it kind of
getting sick of like iced us to watch
Mike aching sick of the universe and the
Marvel and stuff like that and then I
feel like yeah kind of like our new
Galaxy 2 and Doctor Strange and this and
then I'm sure Black Panther likes uh
Civil War yeah path Civil War on it
suddenly it's like ya know like it's
good again like that you like yeah like
I'm actually hiding it what yeah I don't
know what happened but I think it's the
world's man I think it's taken up this
world different worlds and some it was
just I was early like Iron Man was good
I've never been convinced that Iron Man
was the greatest movie ever made it's
just we had nothing else to compare it
to
yeah Herrmann - sucked yeah three of
reading I'm like I'm like threes okay
but I'm not gonna sit there like three
when it was like Tony Stark and the kid
yeah or Pepper Potts boy shut up was
like I thought that was pretty cool I
actually thought the main plot with the
villain was Incredible Hulk was and Thor
was half authority is really really good
erm yeah but yeah but people can't
forget like girls like oh they're on a
hot streak they can do no wrong like
this there's plenty of movies where
they're like hey you know you even
Avengers 2 people are Catholic yeah but
I feel like Civil War on or maybe gonna
die galaxy I'll be straight up honest
like and we talked about this before
like a Mike Avengers is fine I've never
I know somebody was like it is the
greatest comic book movie ever made it's
cool what it did and it's very it's fine
I never
my top 5 for Marvel movies study but
it's fun yeah it's like this it's false
able Avengers 2 yes fun edited bus
honest no I break this movie above
Avengers yeah but it's the same idea
about your personal taste I guess y'all
can crucify me for now but ya know it's
not a you know again it's out dark
tonight changed everything go Richard
are Superman change everything it's like
no this is really really fun and really
really cool you know I can't see
anything
well I'd say kept America though Civil
War and Winter Soldier probably changed
more you know then like Avengers you
know and and this but it's like I really
like this like I would watch this over
probably you know half of the other
Marvel movies even though I like the
other Marvel movies so yes super like it
was already hot streak now it's like a
burning on fire giant flaming monster
that comes up and destroys everything
I'll give DC a compliment this was like
a perfectly executed DC TV show like it
was fun enjoyable entertaining like all
the cool stuff about comic books that
half the time they can't seem to do in
film but it's they do it on TV yeah
where's Martin like I like a lot of the
Marvel shows that is easy to get through
mmm like some of them are just kind of
like dark and it's just like okay this
is good but it's like I wouldn't call it
fun fun yeah this is like like Jessica
Jones it was like okay daredevil like
what the chopstick but it's not but
they're awesome and they're great but
yeah so it reminds me of that I know
what the hell it's just as cool it's
cool you like the trailer you'll
probably like it yeah so you can see go
see it it's cool so cool
you